tyler perry that's my talk of the table
today why
he made a huge donation to the legal
defense fund for briana taylor's
boyfriend that's kenneth walker
tyler perry donated 100 thousand dollars
to the gofundme page supporting mr
walker
walker was with briana taylor when she
was killed by louisville police
who raided her apartment in march and we
spoke with kenneth walker back in
october
an exclusive interview at the time he
says police did not
identify themselves before breaking down
the door walker responded by firing one
shot and police and opened fire
now one of the officers involved in the
involved in the raider was shot in the
leg
is now suing walker for what he saw what
he calls
battery assault and emotional distress
and i think when tyler heard about it he
thought it was outrageous as a lot of
people do
you know kenneth walker's attorney said
to us that he is not convinced that even
that kenneth walker even fired the shot
on the leg because there was a lot of
commotion
a lot of chaos the ballistics report was
inconclusive
then there is a belief that you know
kenneth walker was not the only one that
had a nine-millimeter gun at the scene
that day so it's a very confusing time
yeah
what i remember from your interview was
what a compelling witness yes
walker was but just think about this
guys the gofundme page they were trying
to get one hundred thousand dollars i
think when tyler heard about it it had
maybe
five hundred or a thousand so he's now
just donated the whole 100 thousand that
they were trying this is a lawsuit he's
facing
yes the police officer is filing a
lawsuit there's more lawsuits in this
country than toilet paper later it's
unbelievable